you
well it is my pleasure to welcome
governor Huntsman here to Stanford and
to this program he's accompanied by his
wife Mary Kay who's here joining us Mary
Kay welcome to Stanford and thank you
for joining us the governor has a great
deal of contact with this region and
that the lunch that his grandfather was
the mayor of Palo Alto so he knows this
region very well governor Huntsman has
had their quite distinguished career and
much of it is written in the in the
handout so I'm not going to go into all
a great long introduction but he was
entering his first public service as an
assistant to President Reagan at a very
early age I might say he then became the
Deputy Trade Commissioner at a very
early age he was then the governor of
the Ambassador Singapore again at a very
early age I might say and then he became
the governor of Utah for two terms again
you know at a very early age as I say
and more recently he was the ambassador
to China again at a very early age if he
gets much younger he won't be allowed to
vote but he's had this wonderful
experience in government as well as a
role in business and so we're going to
have a little conversation here you see
this empty chair I'm not going to speak
to it
I'm going to go and sit down with him
and have the conversation so governor
again welcome and I have an opening
question what inspired you to go into
public service well let me put my my
biography into perspective you were very
nice to mention all of those things and
having said all that you know I'm pretty
much unemployed at this point so it
tells you where all of that gets you but
so I'm a failed musician and a failed
politician for the most part and what
does a failed musician do you go into
politics that's the logical that's a
logical progression I guess but what
inspired me most you mentioned my
grandfather hate who was mayor of Palo
Alto when I was born here I was born
here in 1960 I've always held it against
Stanford University because they
wouldn't take my mother when she was big
with baby our family was on the GI Bill
my dad was in the Navy at the time so
they sent her down the road to Redwood
City and I was born at Sequoia Hospital
and I've always kind of held it against
Stanford all these years and they never
took care of my mom
but my grandfather hate who ran the
hardware store here Palo Alto hardware
for many many years he was a navy
officer and my grandfather Huntsman who
was principal of Los Altos high school
down the road was a Navy officer and
their family members sons were in the
Navy as well so everywhere I looked I
saw public servants of a different kind
they were wearing the uniform of the
Navy as my two boys do I have two boys
at the Naval Academy who are preparing
for careers of their own and so during
my formative years all that was talked
about
on the dinner table was service and
doing something good for your community
and giving something back and I I've
always cared that around with me
thinking that as my grandfather Huntsman
would have said who was principal of a
high school the highest rung of success
in life is that of being an educator it
doesn't get any better
my dad failed he went into business and
broke his father's heart I broke my
dad's heart by going into politics not
into business but in the end what is it
that matters most it is it is service as
I like to tell college students around
this country you know when all is said
and done you pretty much have a couple
of words that are etched on your
tombstone of life that kind of
summarizes everything you've done and it
all seems to kind of get right back to
one core principle and that's what
you've done for others service what
you've done for your community so for me
I know it sounds altruistic and and and
and all but I think that's the most
important thing you can do thank you so
this program is China 2.0 and so we're
gonna ask questions about China where
you've had all this great experience and
you've been involved in China for more
than four decades as I understand and
what do you see are the key drivers
behind China's rise their economic rise
what personal experiences can you share
about China's expanding role as a player
in the global economy
you know everyone likes to talk about
their ties to China
at least in my business of diplomacy
which I left not long ago those who are
kind of you know part of the founding
generation of the us-china relationship
my good friend Winston Lord who wasn't
preceded me a couple of times before dr.
Henry Kissinger a friend as well who
really laid the foundation for the
relationship they'd like to talk about
being there at the creation well here's
my story about being there at the
creation yes
the year that Henry Kissinger took a
secret trip to China July of 71 my
father was working for Nixon in the
White House was there for about a year
then couldn't take it anymore and moved
on and the only time I saw my dad was on
weekends and I was out roaming around
the White House a much different kind of
lay of the land in those days looking
for the Coke machine and I ran into a
guy by the name of Al Haig who later
became Secretary of State then Colonel
Haig who worked on the National Security
Council set he said young man do you
want to shake the hand of dr. Kissinger
national security advisor at the time I
don't know who he was I was just I was
just a lost eleven-year-old roaming
around the White House and so I shook
Henry Kissinger's hand didn't register
much he said we helped me carry the bag
out to the car and so I took his black
bag walked to West executive drive which
is just adjacent to the White House for
all the big black sedans used to depart
from and I said where are you going and
he said don't tell anyone it's a secret
he says I'm going to China that didn't
register too much at the time
eleven-year-old kid lost to the White
House looking for the Coke machine but
that was my connection to the opening of
the relationship with China
I helped me carry dr. Kissinger's
bag to the car my friends in China like
to refer to that period 1971 and then
the visit by Nixon in February of 1972
here's what's interesting
can you imagine a President of the
United States forget the party getting
on a plane and traveling to the country
of an antagonist and getting off the
plane and shaking hands with the premier
as Nixon did Joe and lie and later went
on to meet Chairman Mao I mean meetings
that transformed the world just doesn't
happen anymore but my friends in China
and many of you here in this room will
get this part you know that period is
referred to as his drone war drew on
Beijing
which is young China preparing to enter
the world you know at the time in 72 we
were fighting each other in Vietnam we'd
fought years before on the Korean
Peninsula China lost 400,000 men
including the son of Mao Zedong no
commerce no trade no cultural
interaction that was the environment
into which this relationship was born
based on the big balance of power
picture and the Soviet Union and then I
fast-forward history you know to 2001
when I was a trade ambassador and helped
to get China into the WTO after a lot of
work by the Clinton administration and
then the Bush administration in Doha
Qatar November 2001 and my friends in
China refer to that period as drunk
watch in Russia is young China entering
the world and then I fast-forward
history to when I landed there is the US
ambassador in 2009 Republican serving a
Democrat because I think that putting
your country first is probably a good
thing to do and we don't do it enough in
this country and I'm not running for
anything so don't worry about to have a
conversation and an interesting thing
took place in those years you know by
2009 not so long ago the relationship
had gone 40 years of pure bilateral
relationship all of the traditional
bilateral ties and in related issues to
a global relationship and China's rise
was driven by the dung Dynasty which
started with the reemergence of dung
Xiao ping in the late 70s and he'll be
remembered for three things opening the
doors to the world back then China had
no trade with the United States now
we're 400 plus billion dollars soon to
be the largest economic relationship in
the world dung will be remembered by
number two throwing open the doors
diplomatically
to the rest of the world if only you
will abide by a one China policy we can
do business and then number three he'll
be remembered and his dynasty which
comes to an end interestingly enough
next month at the 18th Party Congress
because the new leaders the fifth
generation nobody was anointed by dunk
shopping there are all new comers he'll
be remembered number three by primacy of
the party you know the party will be the
primary organizing unit in politics in
China and that is remain constant and
here it is today the party with I don't
know 80 million members 3900 organizing
units around the country and moving into
the 18th Party Congress wondering how to
stay relevant and I think that'll be a
huge question before everybody as the
fifth generation begins to rise up and
take the reins of power but at what you
you would have had to have been a fool
to think 40 years ago that a country
with 1.3 billion people a large landmass
roughly the size of the United States
with access to raw materials and secure
trade links to all of the major markets
of the world with a history of
capitalism and market expansion proved
1949 wouldn't grow and grow fairly
quickly particularly if you were willing
to manipulate your currency and build up
through investment a large export
machine which you know Taiwan did Korea
did others in the asia-pacific region
relied on a similar economic model and
so here we are not only with the fifth
generation politically beginning to take
the reins but an economic model that is
worn a bit then the investment and the
export model and the desire to move now
more toward more of a consumption model
so is this period in China's history
important no question about it
and is it absolutely critical that
somehow those ties between the United
States and China be enhanced based
around
interests as opposed to those things on
which we disagree which we read about
the paper every day yeah
and that's where we're not getting it
right and it concerns me well thank you
for that very enlightening answer I have
another question it's about China's
political economic challenges and it's
facing they've recently been marked by
sagging markets and property bubble that
seems to be still baiting a little bit
but going on difficulties a consensus in
this change and national leadership we
hear reported are these just bumps in
the road or are there some long-term
issues there that we should understand
and how might we deal with them I think
they're rather historic in nature it's a
fundamental economic transformation it's
it's a fundamental political
transformation and the policies that are
set based upon you know so the five-year
plan most recently that was officially
enshrined last March and the leaders
have began to take over beginning in
November 8th they just announced the
date of the the 18th Party Congress
interestingly enough right about the
same time that we're having US elections
here I think my friends and leadership
in China are getting very smart about
how the cycles of politics were and you
can go through this political transition
and be somewhat under the radar screen
if it happens right about the same time
that the u.s. election happens and they
figure that one out so these are
historic transitions that are happening
and I would I would argue that key key
to success will be the government's
ability to convince the average citizen
in China that they've built enough
confidence into the system in terms of
China's direction that they can now pull
out some of their savings which is very
high and invested in their future
that will be key how do you build
confidence among the average citizens of
China such that they're willing to now
invest more in their future and you say
I wonder if that time has arrived where
there is in fact more confidence in the
overall direction yep you just have to
look back to you know just go back to
the opium wars of 1860 and then the the
the Taiping rebellion of the 1860s and
the Boxer Rebellion of 1900 and the fall
of the Qing Dynasty in 1911 you know the
rise of the party in 1922 23 the
invasion by Japan in the early 30s World
War 2 1949 the Great Leap Forward 62 64
the Cultural Revolution 66 to 76 and you
say people still wonder you know with
every 20 years or so some sort of
disruption in the system an unscheduled
event if you will an incursion a
revolution to take over and the
government's challenge now is to
convince the citizenry that we've got a
safe trajectory ahead that we build
enough confidence in the system and we
can begin to merge from an investment
led model to a consumption model this is
not an easy task and you combine that
with the political challenges of writing
a country with 600 million Internet
users 90 million bloggers having
conversations that would have landed
anyone in a very bad place a few short
years ago how do I know that because I
invited the largest bloggers in the
country to my home when I was ambassador
not everybody showed up because it's not
always a safe place to be in the US
ambassador so for these kinds of
conversations but we had 12 I think that
showed up and some of the largest
bloggers in the country two of them had
readerships of 125 million bloggers and
the kinds of conversations they were
having in my living room about political
reform
about the role of the internet in
society etc we're just profoundly
important and dangerous I might add but
you can't take these conversations and
dismiss them because they're they're
widely discussed and they're important
for the future of China not because the
United States says so we're not saying
that but because the people of China the
next generation coming up are saying so
so the stakes are high and the
challenges are significant in terms of
the pathway ahead so this timing of
Party Congress to obscure the u.s.
election or to know that that that's a
bit the the cynic coming out of me what
I thought what I found in China among
the leadership is some of the brightest
most capable people on the world stage
today who have a much better read of
public relations in public opinion and
the trends of history and politics so by
by comparing and contrasting my first
trip to China I even though I lived in
Taiwan in the 1970s my first trip to
China was with President Reagan in the
early 1980s when he went in 1983 went to
Beijing in Xi'an and Shanghai or he went
to food on food and Austria and he spoke
to the students so I never forget you
know packed in this auditorium about
this size you know students were hanging
out the windows and Ronald Reagan stood
on the stage and spoke to them this is
younger in which he called for nuclear
disarmament I mean if any would he
remembers that speech was pretty
remarkable nobody remembers those days
but it was it was it was quite
remarkable and so here we are in these
cycles and and they continue oh another
question you were there during the
Google conflict two and a half years ago
and their decision to change the way it
operates in China
that led a lot of debate about our
Western companies could operate in China
so as we look back what lessons could be
drawn from that experience one very
simple lesson in the case of Google
consult with the Chinese before you make
a decision that applies many devices
that you know if you have if you have a
partnership in China or even if you
don't even if you have pretty much a
wholly owned subsidiary or corporation
in China it's always a wise thing if
you're making a major market move to
give a heads up to the regulatory people
the regional party bosses something that
would signal that the relationship is
more than just kind of a short-term deal
and I think Google at least my own take
probably learned that very important
lesson that they misfired on the
communication as I remember it was
announced via their site their website
and without a lot of heads up and it it
it caught the leadership forced them
into a corner which is not where you
want to force the leadership if you want
a longer-term relationship and it
thereby made it impossible for them to
do other than anything other than fight
back and to criticize that decision but
it was also at a time when yeah and we
did some reporting on this in the
embassy and the Senate sent some of it
back to Washington State Department
White House note that later showed up in
the WikiLeaks so you know even though
it's classified stuff you know we can
now talk about it now because it's all
out there it's in some of the leaders in
John non-high in their White House you
know we're kind of figuring out what
Google was googling their names and you
know bad stuff would come up they say
this is not a this is not a helpful tool
you know they're criticizing us how can
this be so I think I think going into
the whole Google incident was already
sort of a negative opinion of technology
that brought forth information that
wasn't helpful in China's growth and
evolution thank you for that let's talk
a little bit about the innovation
in China some believe that it's a lot of
sort of meat to firms that are going on
that there a lot of powerful government
policies that drive that now there are
other views that China is really a hot
spot of soon to be new innovations how
do you view that do you have a view of
the role on the level of innovation in
China so what is it that the leadership
would like to do longer term on the
economic side they're gonna have to tame
the SOE s
they're gonna have to figure out how to
regularize them in terms of their
practices they're gonna have to work on
corporate governance transparency
procurement financial transactions
they're gonna have to focus on opening
up some of their markets insurance and
in banking services would be a couple of
them but I think longer-term they'd
really like to crack the code on
innovation how do you do that
that's a tough call you know it's hard
to describe
fully how we do it here in the United
States it just sorta happens when you've
got the right geography access to
capital a lot of smart people good
higher ed institutions and governments
to speak to growth China would like to
do that you've Singapore won it I used
to serve on the Economic Development
Board a Singapore back in the 90s after
I'd served as ambassador in the early
90s and I think China is keenly
interested in how you put the pieces
together for innovation and I think they
will get there at some point not as
fully developed as we are today but I
think they'll begin to develop some of
the elements necessary for innovation
now combining that with innate talent
and brainpower and an entrepreneurial
Drive so in my travels around China
visiting I don't know most of the
provinces over a couple of years I'd
always make it a point to meet with
local entrepreneurs and students because
you get a good sense
from the next generation what's on their
mind what they like and don't like about
the United States you got a lot of
really interesting feedback whether
you're in a big city like Shanghai or
whether you're out you know in in in
shining you know out in the southwest
and what I found to be extraordinarily
powerful in China was the answer for the
the entrepreneurial Drive and I don't
even know that people would term at this
but the ability of this younger
generation to understand the marketplace
to capture opportunities to begin to
naturally network and to take these
small entities increasingly public you
know kind of a billionaire a day kind of
thing and after meeting entrepreneurial
group after entrepreneurial group I
walked away thinking this is the power
of China's tomorrow and when unleashed
there's no looking back it's it is the
it is the entrepreneur in China that I
think is going to drive growth that I
think is going to take to the government
issues about market access about
intellectual property rights protection
because the United States can only go so
far in a government of government basis
and when the entrepreneurs begin to take
hold of these issues I think the outcome
is gonna be a whole lot different over
time but I would have to say innovation
will evolve slowly and what it looks
like visa vie the u.s. type of
innovation you know is certainly an open
question but the raw material for
innovation in the human capital is very
real in China and I walked away with a
strong impression of what that's gonna
mean for China's future just as I walked
away with a view of the modern day
bureaucrat in China the old guys in Mao
suits the central Planning Commission no
English no educated they were
revolutionaries in the early day they
didn't have time to go to school and you
walk into the ministries today foreign
ministry commerce ministry NDRC
English the best universities in the
world and an ability to read the United
States in a very mature and advanced way
insights about my own country that would
impress me and I'd say here's a
challenge for the United States
you've got the bureaucracy in China
that's getting better they're recruiting
good people and they're training them to
do their jobs and you try to find anyone
in the Congress of the United States who
knows anything about the subject matter
and you can't find it you walk into our
departments and agencies and try to find
folks who understand China as well as
they understand us this is a challenge
and somehow someway we're gonna have to
we're gonna have to deal with it in this
country because you don't want to be
disadvantaged at that a go seating table
time after time because you're out done
so on the innovation issue Silicon
Valley has recognized one of the great
centers of innovation technological
innovation and business model innovation
what are the opportunities for
collaboration between China and Silicon
Valley in particular I think the
emerging trends are going to be based on
industries that are compatible with the
direction of the five-year plan so it's
pretty easy to understand where China's
policymaking is going to migrate where
the economy is going to go and where
they focus the emphasis will be under
around the new leadership and that will
be industries and technologies that
support this migration to a consumption
based economy so I would say services of
various kinds what else are they going
to have to do in order to build
confidence in the population you've got
to address healthcare if we forget
sometimes he has 700 million rural poor
in China on a per capita level you know
99 number 99 in the world in terms of
per capita income
China is somewhere between you know the
Democratic Republic of Congo and in
Armenia
retirement financial services travel
tourism healthcare these are all going
to be areas of great focus and
concentration when you look around the
bend and the technologies and the
know-how and the connection with the
digital age that begin to aid and abet
and facilitate some of these services
industries personal services industries
travel and tourism banking healthcare I
think are going to be significant who
mentioned the emerging young people and
youth and they touched on the education
system that you've always had a great
interest in education how would you
assess the training education they're
getting and preparation for the kind of
things you're talking about about the
dealing in a global economy I think it's
getting better the young kids in China
at least many of them that I interacted
with have a great facility facility in
English I was blown away on college
campuses in my interaction with young
kids in auditorium like this after
auditorium their knowledge of the
American system their ability to put the
pieces of the relationship together I
thought we're quite advanced now broadly
speaking I think China's trying to
migrate more toward a different
educational system in the sense that you
go from the rote style to something
that's more critical more Socratic in
terms of student-teacher interaction and
I think they're learning a lot about how
we do it here in the states are better
practices in educating at least at the
primary school level and I think they're
instituting some of those practices in
China
and it's being helped by intellectual
leaders who were educated here in the
United States who are increasingly going
back to China and helping them in this
endeavor now you've kindly agreed to
take some questions of the audience and
so let me see if we have some questions
from the audience we have
microphones here and there if you do
have a question to the governor and you
would just identify yourself and we'll
take the first question over here on my
right governor a couple nights ago
bloomberg reported that Facebook has 63
million users in China and yet
theoretically that's not possible would
you care to comment on the the Great
Firewall yeah in its future well let's
just say I I had some daughters in China
who are very active on on on the
Internet and getting over the Great
Firewall took them all of three and a
half minutes and I thought if my
daughter's can do it so can every other
person in China so the reality is you
can try to throw up a barrier here and
there it doesn't work and it doesn't
last and there are gonna be technologies
that work their way around whatever
barrier you throw up and I think that's
why the the fifth generation of
leadership coming up I think they get
this part and you can only hold back
people so long before you have to come
up with a longer term internet strategy
open the strategy that I think is
consistent both with the political
implications which are very real but
also with the economic development
implications and I'm guessing in the
head of Xi Jinping and in the head of
leakage young and then the head of Wang
Shi Shan and in the head of Wong Young
and then the head of U Junction and in
the head of Jang did young all the
people who are going to occupy positions
at the top maybe even Li yuanchao that
they're thinking in their head we've got
to solve this one and longer-term we
have to have a strategy that's that that
accommodates innovation getting back to
that key pillar on the economic
development side you can't have an
innovative society you can't have the
kind of entrepreneurship broad-based
without access to information and an
active use of the Internet you it's
simply impossible I think they're smart
enough to know that so my guess is that
so you have to give the new leadership
time you can imagine next month
you know 2,000 delegates are going to
descend on Beijing and they're going to
appoint the 200 members of the Central
Committee and about a hundred and fifty
alternates and then they're going to go
into plenary session and they're going
to appoint that 25 members of the
Politburo and then they're going to
figure out the Standing Committee of the
Politburo will it be 7 or will it be 9
you know it was 9 you know in the last
10 years it was seven before 2002 before
the 17th or the 16th Party Congress and
John's Amin when he left you know he
instituted a few changes like a
retirement age of 70 to get shower out
of the out of the Standing Committee and
and then they lowered it that 68 to get
Lee raehwan out of the out of the
Politburo and and so we're gonna see
changes every every step of the way but
I'm guessing we'll be with 7 members of
the Standing Committee and give them a
year or so to consolidate power once
compare is consolidated I think then
reforms begin and top among them I do
believe is going to be dealing with the
Internet in society it's a big one with
political and economic implications but
it can't be avoided forever oh we have a
limited time but we have a number of
people for questions so please make your
questions short and we'll go right over
here Thank You mr. for sharing our your
experience and insight about the US and
China and as well our topic is about
global digital economy I think it's also
about digital global digital generation
still we see in 2008 the digital
generation in the u.s. selected a mr.
Obama as the current president and we
also say in 2010 the digital generation
created the Arab Spring so my question
is about what what I what the things
your truster
Chinese digital generation and what the
concerns about has I fully appreciate if
you could give us some advices Thank You
Sydney Avanti trigger come down like why
Oh Wade ah this this this is a tough one
to answer and it's a great question and
I wish I had more in the way of real
insights there there's a very tech-savvy
generation in China that's coming up and
a very networked generation you all know
the numbers in terms of cell phone usage
and internet usage and all and on one
end and if remember last time I spoke
out on this subject on the Arab Spring
my name was banned from the internet in
China so I was yeah the outcome wasn't a
good one
but the the generation that you are part
of will drive change and I think that's
very good
and you should maintain your
conversations about your aspirations
your goals for your generation the flip
side of that is the speed with which you
can change the system you know we want
change and we want it now the system
will only be able to accommodate so much
in the way of change in the next few
years
timed you know to hit certain political
cycles you might I think we're gonna
have probably I don't know a three to
five year opening a window after Xi
Jinping
and his generation consolidate power for
change before they have to close things
again because any watcher of observer of
Chinese politics would tell you that you
know at Ebsen flows before every Party
Congress you know of where there's a
party congress every five years and has
been since the death of Mao Zedong in
1976 you know you have a little opening
and then you have to close up and yeah a
little the opening and then you have to
draw back so change yes your generation
will bring that about and based on the
digital economy
but it's the expectations of your
generation and where things might go
that could cause for some wind shears
now and again politically and it's hard
to know how that will play out so I
think time is nearing an end and we'll
take one more question
sorry to disappoint all the other people
you've been so good of all these answers
here
but let's take a question over here our
last one
governor Huntsman thank you for joining
us today I'm a local venture capitalists
Terry Garnett who went here to the
business school
the Chinese appear to be very savvy
about their foreign policy especially
trying to drive an economic agenda and I
think Governor Romney recently touched
about how we should use foreign aids
more strategically economically and as a
foreign governor former ambassador I'm
curious do you think we should
restructure the State Department the way
we staff at the type of person who runs
it to make it a more economic
organization as opposed to you know the
kind of issues we get into which I think
it is in trouble around the world you
know it's it's such a valid point
China's foreign policy is driven by one
sovereignty you look at the maps from
the Ching dynasty 1911 1912 that which
was laid out as our territory including
shinjang and Tibet and Macau and Hong
Kong and Taiwan and South China Sea and
the tiu Islands etc etc that will be our
goal to begin to recover the lost
territory and everything's pretty much
been recovered except a couple of those
and then beyond that it's an economic
approach which i think is sound foreign
policy why because strong economics is
going to facilitate growth at home which
keeps unemployment low and stabilizes a
political system I mean pretty pretty
much kind that keeps the party in power
back to dung shoppings driving
philosophy from his days in power in the
United States we have a hard time
recognizing that economics should be
salient
in our foreign policy if we got that
part we wouldn't have the bureaucracy
that we do you know we would have taken
the Department of Commerce Department of
Treasury the US Trade Representative's
office functions within the State
Department functions within the National
Security Council and reorganized around
something that unifies and coordinates
better or economic policy agenda and we
would lead with economic policy because
that is the music that the rest of the
world tends to want to dance to and it's
also there are the issues that carry
real leverage in today's global economy
and the Chinese understand that the
foreign policy should be led by
economics for all the reasons we've
discussed and I think our future will
absolutely depend on being able to
recognize first and foremost a proper
use of economic policy driving our
foreign policy so let me just end with
this thought how do you clean up the
Middle East after we've kind of been
there for ten years you got to clean it
up I mean we have a mess and a lot of us
because of bad policy from the United
States and we haven't had a conversation
in this country about that yet but we
have to at some point recognize the
region the Middle East what we have done
based upon our pilot and how we can make
it better the only answer to my mind is
we have to start utilizing our economic
policy levers because you've got to
address the pockets of despair whether
in North Africa or the broader Middle
East or South Asian region when there is
despair and unemployment what do you do
you turn to radicalism and the madrasa
movement facilitates that we've got to
somehow put in those pockets of despair
through free trade agreements or
economic initiatives regional economic
initiatives some sort of growth agenda
it gives people and our exporters you
know something everybody comes out ahead
and I hope that we wake up in the near
term and find that we have a stronger
international economic policy in this
country
Oh governor thank you very much